this was the verdict ahmed aburi's
family had hoped for
that is life plus 20.
travis mcmichael and his father gregory
given the maximum sentence for murdering
25-year-old aubry after chasing him
through a georgia neighborhood in
february of twenty twenty william roddy
brown who joined in the chase was given
a mandatory murder sentence of life
imprisonment but with the possibility of
parole after thirty years the judge said
that he unlike his co-defendants had
displayed some remorse
all three can appeal their sentences but
also face a federal hate crimes trial
next month
before the sentencing members of aubry's
family made their case
the man who killed my son has
said in this courtroom
every single day
next to his father
i'll never get that chance
to sit next to my son elba
again
and aubry's mother addressed her son
directly i made a promise to you
today i laid you to rest
i told you i love
you and someday
somehow
i would get you justice
the presiding judge said he'd thought
deeply about the case he even paused in
silence for a minute to suggest how long
aubry had been running in fear of his
life before he was murdered
a fraction of the time
that a mod armory was running in
statilla shores
and in rendering his verdict the judge
alluded to the racial fault lines of
this community in the deep south
i argue that maybe a neighbor is more
than the people who just own property
around your house
i believe that is also believe that in
assuming the worst in others
we show our worst character
outside the court aubry's mother thanked
those who supported her family and made
reference to one of the most shocking
moments of the trial when one of the
prosecutors alleged her son was not a
victim but a criminal quote with no
socks to cover his dirty toenails the
long toenails that she bought up in our
closing arguments
she she failed to mention that ahmad was
lying there in the middle of the road
with a big hole in his chest
outside the court there was celebration
and accountability for the murder of a
black man by white man in the south too
many of them still haven't gotten
anybody arrested for killing their child
so this is about all of us saying no
more
no more but it should be remembered that
in the aftermath of arbory's killing the
police and local authorities did nothing
accepting the word of those now
convicted of murder that arbory had been
up to no good only when video evidence
was released weeks later did state
authorities act she abertansi al jazeera